ty jerome ken rich williams you're five
for okc
alexander walker to guard the inbounder
kitty's got to get it in
no timeouts the ball is inbounded to
shea temple
did not fail
[Applause]
oh
it off
sheer disbelief
from paycom center
as they will go over and review this
in what is an incredible finish ingram
thinks it's good the pelicans think it's
good
and now we await
replay confirmed successful three-point
basket
oh and devante graham breaking the
hearts
[Applause]
of the thunder
as sga's incredible shot tied it michael
at 110.
i was blocked i couldn't see a temple
was trying to foul or not yeah
look he's trying to follow him right
there
awfully close
as shane knocks down and before we can
even talk about it
i mean look at he's fouled and trying to
follow him right there there it is
and he kind of looked at the official
look i'm trying to foul
and before we can even take a breath
this is what happened next folks
[Applause]
from
70 feet
the heave to win it
by devonta graham
his fifth
and final
victorious three
and the celebration onset
by the pelicans what
a finish
here in downtown oklahoma city
barely got that shot off
before that light lit up and i look at
the expression of sga that says it all
because he made a terrific shot
to tie this ball game
momentarily
disbelief on one side
purely